30 seconds did you ever think you were
made
sweet victory I know this life meant for
me yeah why would you plan on Goliath
when we got bit David now you came and
giving values contagious this world are
entrepreneurs we gain no value to haters
[Music]
because it's the what it's done anyways
uh folks today's a special podcast 59
years ago today
a president who was loved uh by tens of
millions of people around the world was
assassinated and 59 years later
today we have a very uh simple Mission
our mission is in two hours to solve who
was behind that assassination okay and
to do that we have a few special guests
today one we have James D Eugenio who uh
wrote the book JFK Revisited who this
turned out ended up being a
of a documentary a film there's four
parts there's one part there's a bunch
of different things with it at Oliver
Stone here a few months ago we talked
about the book together but uh James
deuginio's book here with Oliver Stone
we have him here to my left he's the
co-founder of two organizations the
citizens for truth about Kennedy
assassination and the Coalition of
political assassinations
he was a co-editor of the assassinations
a book on the death of death of JFK MLK
Robert Kennedy and Malcolm X thank you
for being on the podcast
my pleasure we also have David Montauk
am I saying it correctly Montague
montaguear on the podcast as well he is
the associate Vice Chancellor of
academic Affairs at the University of
Arkansas at Little Rock
uh he earned PhD at Howard University
very great powerful University a lot of
friends went there for political science
nma at George Washington University in
crime and commerce And a ba in Morehouse
College in political science he was an
investigator for The Drug Enforcement
Administration hence DEA and
intriguingly was the head of
Investigations for the United States JFK
assassination's record review board
thank you for being on the podcast as
well and we have two other guests that
will join us at 10 o'clock
at the same time one will be from
Belarus that's going to be joining us
the one joining us from Belarus
is Ernest tiovets who is a friend of
um Lee Harvey Oswald they hung out
together in Russia he's got his own
perspective of uh who he really was and
the other person that'll be joining us
will be Paul Gregory when he came back
to the states in Dallas they had a
friendship together they'll give us our
perspective on what he was really like
was HE capable of doing what he did what
was the experience of a friendship with
them and I will take it from there so
the reason why we have uh both of you
here is because you both have a
different feeling of what happened uh
with the the JFK assassination event now
here's what's interesting everybody
needs to know both of you were at the
same event the Justice you came from
Dallas we flew both of you guys out from
Dallas with Cyril wax event that's
taking place in Dallas right now which
the events called citizens against
political assassinations uh we're glad
we're having these types of events so
there's not any political assassination
so James if you don't mind take a um
minute and if you can introduce yourself
to the audience your back background why
the fascination with this topic and then
we'll take it from there all right
um I I've been uh working this field
almost non-stop for approximately 30
some years
all right and uh the reason I got
interested in this is that
several years after Jim Garrison did his
interview in Playboy I I picked this up
and I read the interview and I thought
God this is really fascinating this guy
had like a lot of interesting insights
into what really happened
and so then
um after I graduated from film school at
Cal State North A friend of mine asked
me well why don't you try and do a
screenplay and I said about what and he
said well what are you really interested
in and I thought well this would make a
very good subject this Garrison God so
then I worked on this for a while and
then I picked up the daily variety and I
read that Oliver Stone had purchased the
rights to Jim Garrison's book and I go
well there goes that idea
and so what I did is I turned my
research into the my very first book
which was the first edition of Destiny
betrayed and then I uh started Pro
magazine uh citizens for truth about the
can which then which was an early
website and today I run the website of
kennedysandking.com the reason this has
stayed with me for so long is as time
goes on and I see the political
situation that we have in this country
I I really do believe that Kennedy's
assassination was a landmark in a
steadily
disabling country you know they're not
somehow has lost its way and you know if
you're haunted by the past which I think
we all are in this case then I don't
think you can really understand the
present all right so that's why you know
I from an historical view that's why
I've still worked this case
how about yourself
you know um
I wasn't alive when President Kennedy
was uh killed assassinated and
you know in connection I do agree I said
that they think that the the Kennedy
assassination Martin Luther King's
assassination Bobby Kennedy
certainly Pinnacle moments that impacted
our history and you know I mentioned I
mentioned at the conference last week
that I the Morehouse College of school
it was the same school that Dr King
attended so
um you know I grew up in the DC area and
we had a very patriotic family uh just
believed in you know of course you know
taking advantage of the opportunity to
vote
um being active and and and you know and
and understanding the world around us
and by happenstance I ended up joining
the review board and you know and in all
honesty I I had no you know Jim talks
about kind of how you learned more about
it and it became intrigued same thing
kind of happened for me because I
remember you know I was with DEA at the
time I took an Amtrak down to DC from
New Jersey
and when I sat across the desk from
David marwa who was the director
executive director of the assassination
records reward
you know he was kind of explaining uh
you know what the agency was about and
in my mind I'm piecing it together like
there's a federal agency to look at
specifically this and I had no idea as
to you know how deep and how many other
investigative groups you know think
about it compared to like 911 there's
been one 911 Commission and then you
think of the multiple commissions the
groups and put together to look at these
assassinations
um and so it really became something of
great interest to me just as a unique
opportunity
um I had come with a lot of investigate
like interviewing experience
um I had worked the white collar side of
DEA so I would interview a lot of people
you know
uh and so you know for me one of the
most interesting thing was uh getting a
chance to talk to uh Witnesses
kind of re getting them to read you know
in some cases for the first time opening
up and they felt they couldn't before
people in tears so you know this this
this uh
these events you know impacted my life
in a major major way
and you know one of the things that I
think that is important is for people
not to forget
the records need to be released
December 15 Joe Biden apparently uh were
being told the records for John FK
assassination uh are going to be
released and the reason why they said it
wasn't released uh because we were
supposed to get it earlier what
significant impact that a covid-19
pandemic if you guys remember that
October 23 2021 but hopefully by
December 15 2022 it'll be released and
Trump was also one that hesitated a
little bit to releasing the docs it
seems to be a trend I mean it's been 59
years and they're still not releasing it
uh what What's your speculation on why
this thing keeps getting uh backed up I
I think your audience probably needs a
little background on what the review
board was and why we're in this
situation today when JFK came out back
in 1991 it created a firestorm of
controversy and because at the end of
his film Oliver Stone wrote that the
files of the house select committee are
classified until the year year 2029
which was the last investigation and
they closed in 1979 so the question was
why do we have to wait
50 years to learn the last things about
John F Kennedy's assassination so
Congress created this what we call
assassination's record review board
which had unprecedented powers in the
history of record declassification
well they did not finish their work they
only had a four-year Lifetime and so
what happened is
this dragged on and dragged on and
dragged on the terminal date where
everything was supposed to be let go was
2017. so that comes up and Trump says
about a week before I'm really looking
forward he Tweets in I'm really looking
forward to releasing these last files on
the JFK assassination and so what
happens he doesn't right he didn't why
are they afraid of releasing it this is
what was in the most of the papers is
that he got a last minute visit by the
FBI right and the CIA and what what
these guys do and because I I know this
for a fact is that they come in and they
and they read the riot act so and by the
way let me add this the only person who
could have stopped a declassification
was the president because it says that
right in the law and so they they
usually give you the speech about if you
if you let these go you're gonna danger
the life of a lifelong agent or some
kind of ongoing operation now how the
same agent could be in place 50 years
later is really amazing to me so he
what he did is he asked for a six-month
extension
then when the six-month extension was up
he asked for a three-year extension
which actually went beyond his
presidency and so this then bounce to
Biden all right and Biden uh released I
think about 1400 pages
and he said we have to wait because Nara
is somehow behind the curve due to the
coveted uh epidemic you know what what
they were doing in the intervening 20
years I don't know okay and so now now
the new terminal date is about three or
four weeks from now December the 15th
and I can tell you for a fact
that Biden was already planning to delay
that because I know some of the lawyers
you're aware that got a lot of publicity
that they filed a lawsuit against Biden
and Nara in Northern California to force
the declassification Well in that
lawsuit they have that information that
he was already planning on another delay
but what's the do you know the reasoning
behind it I mean it's it's got one he
was on the review board so why why are
you guys delaying it as you know maybe
we ought to blame you what is wrong with
you
why do you think they're delaying it if
you were to give your perspective before
we get into what we really think
happened so so I'm you know I I this is
a very personal thing for me after all
the work that we put in
uh to actually find people you know uh
find records or arrange Deeds of gift
transfer of Records to the National
Archives and Records Administration all
the visits to archives one and two and
other facilities around the country to
do research
just like Jim said you know I kept
looking on the JFK collection it's on
the National Archives records
Administration website to see my record
group
and here's the interesting thing
uh you can find records of mine in other
people's records groups but not in mine
which doesn't make sense right so I I'm
just as upset about this because in my
mind we were doing that work to
literally provide a centralized place
and and let the American people decide
you know don't hold a thing back I mean
yes I was taught to do you know Skip
tracing find people things like that we
didn't have Google
um that that's a skill you have to be
taught to do that there are sources and
methods associated with how I was able
to do that I don't think those things
should be released however it like you
said it doesn't take 20 years to to just
take those things and what threat and
you have to really have an actual threat
against the country against Nationals so
so you know you know uh uh you watch
movies like article about what is that
sound that clicking noise you hear it
what is that clicking noise it's like
somebody's clicking something do you
hear that okay so you know can I can I I
want to say something hang tight so so
I'm from Iran okay and I watched the
movie Argo and you watch the movie Argo
with Ben Affleck and you see what's
going on in Iran with the whole movie
Canada everything that they did they
waited 30 years like how come you didn't
release this early well you gotta wait
30 year CIA whatever the numbers are
right
and then you look at this this is 59
years okay it's similar to when they
said you know the the covet
investigation cannot take place till
2076 or whatever the number that they
put that's like 50 years from now 40
years from now right 50 years from now
and they're like Why Can't This Be not
investigated for 50 years is it because
the people who are making those
decisions are not going to be around 50
because so so then it goes back to the
point of 1963 today 59 years most of
those guys have been dead that were part
of it anyways only a few people of that
right so who who's protecting who at
this point is it a legacy what's being
protected see one of the things that
John tuneheim talked about when we
interviewed him and his the rest of his
interviews in the book all right he said
these guys really they don't want to
give up anything all right and he said
he described the first meeting with the
CIA
and he said he threw up a document on
the screen
and he said what on Earth could you
possibly object to right and
declassifying that document because to
him there was nothing in it that seemed
to endanger anything all right and so
the CIA guy looked at the document for
about a minute or so
and they're waiting and waiting and he
says give me a couple of minutes I'll
think of something see that's the kind
of attitude these guys have that's been
inbredded into their well-being I I you
know I uh I was hoping we could figure
it out right now but apparently we can't
force these guys to release them maybe
we got to take a different route let me
first look at what I want to talk to you
guys about pull up the different uh
conspiracy theories that that we have
Jiffy JFK assassination conspiracy
theories the grassy knoll umbrella man
which I think was actually in his 1991
movie that Oliver Stone did LBJ Ted
Cruz's dad obviously that came out of
nowhere during the elections right
there's so many different stories that
we read about you know Jack Ruby the mob
I've interviewed Sammy the bookervano
Michael Francis they said the mob had to
do with it Clint Hill said no I I think
it's just exactly what people think it's
Harvey Lee Harvey Oswald Jim Jenkins who
was in the room holding John fk's brain
one of the four people in the room so
this just didn't make sense it looks
like somebody cut it before they did and
then you know the new brain weighs 1500
pounds how does the brain weigh 15 not
59 grams 1500 grams after it's been shot
that doesn't make there's so many
different things that you hear with
these conspiracy theories and some are
just playing it safe and saying no Cyril
wex says this doesn't makes he's trying
to figure it out from his perspective
but I want to hear your views on what
happened and before we get into these
topics and have our guests from Belarus
as well as two of Lee Harvey Oswald's
former friend one claims that we're best
friends give theirs perspective one is a
doctor now they're both ones with the
Hoover Institute the other one's a
doctor I believe in Belarus was in their
Olympic team or national team so these
are not just regular people in the
streets given their opinions they have
some perspective to give let me go to
our sponsors first today's uh podcast is
sponsored by goldco
if you're watching this your hard worker
you're seeing what's going on with
inflation interest rates and everybody's
concerned about what's going to be
happening for me I years ago decided to
hedge against inflation by buying gold
and I've been doing this for many many
years I have physical I own funds that
have to do with gold and whether it's
gold silver we decided to team up with
gold because we did a lot of
Investigation we called many different
friends who have been in this business
some that sold with competitors of gold
coin some that sold wood goldco
eventually after two years of talking
about who we're going to team up with
for gold we decided apartment with
goldco and give them a call today to
learn more about protecting your savings
and as a vitamin viewer you could get up
to ten thousand dollars in free silver
that's right ten thousand dollars in
free silver when it comes on to precious
metal reputation matters that's why we
chose goldco called them today at
855-598-2758 or click on the link below
in the description or the chat to go to
goldco again
855-59827 58 okay so let's get right
into it James
I'll go to you first okay what do you
think happened there's a lot of theories
based on where you are from your
different uh uh access to information
that you have are any of these
conspiracy theories do you give them any
credibility or do you say no you know
what we know is exactly what happened
where do you stand with it you know you
know it's interesting that's a great
question because I remember David
marwell made the comment when he was
interviewing me because Ann butterman
was actually head of Investigations when
I first came on board and when she left
I took over
um surprise I didn't expect it
um and obviously technology played a big
role in how we're able to do our
investigative work but to your question
you know I
I you know I walked in David Marvel made
the comment that that one of the reasons
he wanted to hire me was because
um I did not have a perspective either
way when they hired me you know um we
did have some people that were um single
bullet some people that were conspiracy
uh that worked there you know and quite
frankly I will say I I really enjoyed my
co-workers working with them we went
through a lot of things I did have some
people try to tell me to not push on
certain topics when people bring things
to my attention and I always saw do any
investigative work as as wide of a net
as possible until I really understand I
need to follow it if somebody brings it
turn away from assassination research
Community or government or whatever a
witness
um you know I interviewed a lot of
people I talked to a lot of folks I had
to review Oswald's belongings at
archives too
um all the investigative material you
know including some you know body things
things from his body
um
and you know after looking at the
autopsy photos the the brain of record
all those different things my personal
take is I don't see how anyone could
have assassinated the president alone
that's my personal take how anyone could
have I think it was a conspiracy okay so
you think there was somebody involved
into shooting it wasn't just Lee by
himself I think I think there is
definitely more than one person for sure
okay and so what which direction have
you if you're in that space I'm assuming
you've spent endless hours studying it
so do you have an idea or even a level I
mean at this point of the game to say a
hundred percent it's very hard to say
100 everything is theories that we're
trying to you know get closer to it but
what do you think happened if you're
saying another person which one do you
believe so so you know there there was
the the radio evidence that Robert
groden put in during the hsca I had
talked to Witnesses and deal applies
like James Tague for instance and others
um there were so many people that kept
talking about uh they they thought shots
were coming from uh the front you know
and
um what they with the officials and the
day again statements to law enforcement
and that those statements did not end up
in the warrant report I mean I didn't
make those things up people just
independently were saying those things
to me when I was you know tracking them
down and talking to them
and so after a while I was like hey this
I I wasn't there you know I've I've
studied I did read a lot of books
associated with the assassination
um I did work very closely with like
Doug horn and others
um to really get perspective on the
different stories Associated but you
know a lot of the folks that I talk to I
mean I walked away not physical things
the stories uh I don't see how any one
person could have done that James
um
on the day of the assassination
uh Malcolm Perry and
um Kim Clark two doctors who worked on
Kennedy in the ER room at Parkland had a
press conference
briefing the Press on what they had
found and Malcolm Perry
stated
that
Kennedy was hit in the front of his
throat by
and entering projectile
Kemp Clark said
that there was a large gaping hole in
the back of JFK's head
both those would indicate that there
were shots from the front all right
because Exit Wounds leave much larger
all right and so
as Malcolm Perry was leaving
the podium
a guy in his in a suit grabbed him by
the arm and he said don't ever say that
again
this is an hour and 45 minutes after JFK
was killed
that evening
at a in the morning early in the morning
Perry got a call from the Bethesda
morgue
and it was the
Humes and Boswell to the Pathologists
working on Canada
we're trying to talk him out of his
story
and they said if you don't take that
back we're going to bring you before a
medical board and get your license taken
away
now to me that would indicate somebody
is snapping on the cover-up about this
thing within 24 hours of Kennedy's
assassination and it wasn't any mobster
okay it wasn't any Cuban Exile it was
somebody in a high position
because we know that in the morgue that
night
there were very high position Pentagon
brass and one of the guys there Apollo
Connor said that Humes told him to go
over to the gallery
and tell that guy in the corner to take
that cigar out of his mouth
and he walks over O'Connor walks over
and
he looks at it and it's Curtis LeMay The
Joint Chiefs of Jeff the Air Force he
walks back to Humes and he says I can't
tell that guy to think that's Curtis
LeMay what was Lemay doing there
that night and so these are all
indications that this was kind of a high
level plot all right to go ahead and get
and to get and and like I trying to
animate
I believe
that the cover-up was planned with the
conspiracy
the cover-up was planned with the
conspiracy yes meaning meaning that they
knew that they had this concealed
certain things immediately
after they assassinated JFK and they
were looking for ways to do it in
advance
another example being
I'm sure you're aware of this Jefferson
Morley and his work on Johnny's the eye
official his group
had the first newspaper blaming
Oswald of Killing Kennedy for Castro
that was like within 24 hours of the
assassination they were getting that
story out
and that was a CIA sponsored Journal
that was a cie sponsor they were paying
a pair of 24 hours prior to that so so
no 24 hours after 24 hours after so so
when you when you hear um
so so for me I look for motive and I
look for strategy and I look for strange
you know uh uh
you know you know reasons why somebody
wants it to happen doesn't want it to
happen the enemy of an enemy is a friend
the enemy of A friend is an enemy all
this stuff that you look at right okay
so let's look at it there are pictures
can you pull a picture of not this one
if you can pull out pictures of John F
Kennedy and LBJ John F Kennedy looking
at LBJ okay so when you look at John F
Kennedy looking at LBJ there are many
instances where you know uh um you just
don't see a lot of trust in the way he
looks at him you don't see a lot of uh
oh
um
where you know he's worried what's going
to happen here so it's kind of like the
case where he has to go get him as a VP
to help him because he had Texas and etc
etc and he had a lot of power and LBJ
was more driven to become a president
than JFK was JFK wasn't really supposed
to be the president out of the Kennedy
was supposed to be Joseph the oldest son
John F Kennedy kind of like he's the
last guy that ends up becoming a
president so you look at LBJ a lot of
ambition there to become a president
okay that's one person you look at the
other one mob what uh you know John F
Kennedy was trying to do uh to the Mob
making their life a little bit tougher
RFK his brother so could have been the
conversation of the mob talking to each
other where you have this uh a potential
conversation with multiple mob bosses
talking to each other saying look are
you seeing what RFK is doing targeting
everybody after we helped him out in
Chicago or Illinois yes we got to take
this guy out one of them my bosses says
if we take him out John F Kennedy is
going to spend the rest of his life life
targeting us but if we take John F
Kennedy out RFK loses his power he won't
be able to do anything we start with
John F Kennedy first and then we go to
RFK we're done with and we don't have to
worry about them coming after us so okay
cool let's go that route and then you
know if you've seen Godfather 2 there's
a scene in Godfather too where in Lake
Tahoe they're trying to kill Michael
they come and shoot up Michael's house
with the glasses I don't know if you've
seen this one scene where it's getting
shot up and then right afterwards you
see them in a creek there are a couple
other guys come and shoot them and
they're dead and the shooters are you
know dead at this point nobody can find
that who paid them to come and try to
kill Michael if a mobster is trying to
kill somebody they hire somebody to kill
the person and then they hire somebody
to kill the killers who are going to
kill the person so you can sit here and
speculate and look at all this stuff to
see what the motive is who benefited the
most from John F Kennedy being
assassinated
um I don't know if you're aware of this
uh after the 26 volumes of the Warren
Commission were published which was in
November of 1964.
three months later
Johnson sent the first combat troops to
Vietnam
that's a line that Kennedy was never
going to cross and that's very clear to
any historian who studies this case and
I don't have to tell you
what a big amount of money was made on
dredging up things like Cameron Bay Bell
helicopters Huey Etc you're talking
about hundreds of millions of dollars
okay that were spent over there and so
this is why some people
consider uh
what Eisenhower referred to which I'm
sure you're aware of what he called the
military industrial complex we much
never let them encroach on our human
rights and Liberties all right so I
believe that that was at least part of
the reason
for see look this whole debate that
sprouted after JFK came out
they now have these these guys
Declassified so many records on this
issue of this whole issue about Vietnam
that I don't think is debatable anymore
JFK was never going to go into Vietnam
and he was getting out at the time of
his assassination I'm sure you're aware
of that that he the issued in order and
remember Patrick
there were no combat troops in Vietnam
only advisers at the time of JFK's death
there was not one combat troop in when
he was inaugurated there was not one
combat troop in today he was
assassinated
LBJ changes all of that within a matter
of of weeks some say it's actually days
all right and there's that famous scene
in in JFK which I'm sure you're aware of
where he's talking to the Joint Chiefs
and he says
just get me reelected and I'll give you
your warn okay so I think that's one of
the very serious motives in the JFK
assassination
I'll just pick it back I agree with that
I I'll piggyback uh as well and talk
about you mentioned RFK I mean you know
it's it's no secret you know that
um you know before I heard of Evelyn
would uh and she is was on a record on a
documentary talking about LBJ and the
discussion between Bobby Kennedy and and
JFK and and getting LBJ on the ticket to
put him on the ticket with him for VP
you know and what a heated conversation
and you talked about the lack of trust
you know and then that was clear from
the beginning
um but you know I think you know Jim
just you know is exactly right there was
there was tension for different goals of
the two people for sure between the two
you know JFK and and LBJ
um and you also Jim mentioned uh Curtis
LeMay you know the joint cheese you know
there's a very famous movie made about
it's called seven days in May uh you
know old black and white film about uh
you know let's coup uh you know uh and
and we we think about the the level of
power struggle that that we're talking
about here and and of course you know as
I mentioned before both Bobby Kennedy
you know being so
um uh um uh insistent and working very
diligently to fight organized crime
organized crime was a dirty word back
then it was the allegedly non-existent
you know and there were a lot of people
that didn't like so my point is there
were several people I do think the the
the push to try to do Vietnam was a huge
thing there are a lot of people that
these other these civil rights issues uh
fighting organized crime there are a lot
of people that had a lot of different
motives
Patrick you're aware that Kennedy liked
that book so much
that he got out of the white house so
they could film John frankenheimer was a
director and he's that's a great book
I'll get out of the White House you can
use it as a prop okay
that's how much he was so concerned
about what the story was
can I add one more thing yeah because
it's interesting you know as as you
mentioned you know when we were doing
our work our mandate was really
different you know and at first I didn't
realize how different our mandate as an
agency was to be able to do the work we
did we still have something we weren't
able to finish like we said you know but
the the when you talk about motive the
fear in the general public that the lack
of trust that people lost their trust in
government uh after the assassinations
happened and so many people were just
completely amazed that they were free to
talk you know and it was something to
you had to you had to be there to to be
part of that and to experience that that
there were a lot of people uh that you
know we had subpoena power a lot of
people requested subpoenas to be able to
come and bring records and for a while a
lot of people didn't believe they
actually could talk to us
a lot of people didn't think they could
talk to you right okay so Tyler if you
can another thing I want to bring up is
the following the story about and I
don't know where you guys stand with
this uh the story about
um uh George Bush Senior you know for
many years asked where were you on that
day were you in Dallas you were seen in
Dallas I wasn't in Dallas there's a lot
of talks about George Bush Senior if he
can pull up that one picture I just sent
you uh this one here if you zoom in a
little bit
you know that's uh him to the right on
how he stands and then that's him to the
left in Dallas uh at the you know Book
Depository so you you hear why wasn't he
there why wasn't you know why wasn't why
doesn't he say where he was at why does
he not remember that was there any is
there any credibility to seniors
involvement in this you're asking yeah
no
that that's not him the picture of him
in D Lee Plaza he was there the day
before okay the day of the assassination
he was in a little town called Tyler
Texas which I believe is a home of Earl
Campbell and he was uh he was addressing
a group of businessmen also also city of
uh
the legend yes
there were at least 100 people there
yeah okay so no that that's now what now
now if you're going to tell me was he
CIA did he concealed his I agree with
that you know when he became CI director
which I think was 75 or 76. you know he
he I believe he was dishonest when he
said he had no connections with this
yeah yeah so so okay so here's another
question for you with the family John F
Kennedy who who feared the the Kennedy
Legacy Family to think that maybe these
guys can be in office for 16 years you
know this could be a possibility where
you know John F Kennedy first eight and
then Bobby 8 16 Kennedys are going to be
you know running the country they're
going to have power over everything we
have to slow this down who feared for
the possibility of that happening you
wanna you wanna answer anything
I well I think I think that we we talked
about some of the you know
um uh in terms of economics I say a lot
of a lot of folks have theorized that it
was the uh the oil
industry as well but um in terms of
lbj's connection but there are a lot of
things as I mentioned before that the
Kennedy family you know a lot of people
didn't like them to begin with and feel
that they were worthy of holding office
um and at the same time they were
pushing an agenda that was changing the
course or threatened to change the
course and to to of the of America to
actually focus on other types of issues
and topics there were a lot of people
that were very uncomfortable with that
and again that's why it rightly so uh
there have been like we looked at all
three we looked at Bobby Kennedy Martin
Luther King assassination and also
um JFK and just like if you look at the
hsca records
um you know having investigators
literally looking at primarily uh the
JFK and MLK as well
um and you can see that even if you go
to Memphis and and and see the The
sniper's Nest you know from Martin
Luther King and to see where they talk
about the work of the hsca you know and
all those different things who would be
the modern day uh Kennedy last name is
it is it a fair comparison to say the
modern day Kennedys would be a trump
where a lot of people in the swamp were
not fans of us or these are complete
opposite uh comparisons what would you
say well
John F Kennedy if you take a look at his
record
he was trying to pass Medicare yeah he
was talking about Universal Health Care
and he was really the first president
that actually stood up
for civil rights even though knowing
that this was really going to hurt very
few people know this
Robert Kennedy
wrote a resignation letter
on November the 21st
because he says I have cost you at least
half the states in the South with this
civil rights program okay if you
remember Kennedy forced opened the
University of Mississippi you know there
was a huge Riot there two people were
killed all right and then a few months
later he forced open the University of
Alabama
at that confrontation
Kennedy ordered 3 000 American troops in
case George Wallace was going to bring
in the state troopers Etc all right so
if you ask me there really isn't anybody
you know today uh that can compare with
both his Kennedy's ability to win very
big elections and also the kind of
progressive kind of attitude that he had
right all right in fact if you take a
look at his civil rights record Kennedy
had more for civil rights in three years
than Truman Eisenhower and FDR did in
three decades
all right it's that simple yeah I I
understand what you're saying but also
at the same time some people would say
if he ran today on his policies he's not
a Democrat he would be running as an
independent or a center right type of a
guy because he was for low taxes he was
about low regulation he was pro-business
he was uh many of those qualities today
that would be seen as a center right not
a you know a person that's a full-on
Democrat I I I I I don't see how
standing up to the steel companies and
forcing them to their knees in 48 hours
is a pro-business I mean nobody did that
before and nobody's done that are you
you wear what I'm talking about yeah he
caught the steel companies trying to rig
prices they basically challenged him on
this and so him and his brother three
o'clock in the morning were issuing
subpoenas to the steel company
Executives all right so you know I I I
don't think that that's what a true
capitalist would fight against that a
true capitalist would be and and that by
the way to me is a true capitalist by
the way that's what that's what he's not
going after you know living in a country
where there's only two countries in a
world where big Pharma can do
advertisement one is us one is New
Zealand and nobody has the audacity to
stand up against them you're not in
capitalism if you allow these big Pharma
companies spending billions of dollars
on lobbyists every year and you know
doing commercials on all these different
news stations CNN NBC all these places
that are getting all these ads because
hey here's another 10 million another
five million other three million billion
that's to me is fighting for capitalists
when these guys are price gouging uh if
you're talking about steel at that time
today you can talk about big Pharma one
pill takes 20 cents to come make you're
selling it for 200 and no one's willing
to go up against those guys because
there's so much money coming from the
back end if a person goes after big
Pharma to me you are a capitalist so for
John F Kennedy to be doing that I would
say yeah that's a pro-capital as a move
I wouldn't say that say you know Pro
liberal move I'd say it's for
pro-capitalism
um
I don't know if you know there's
1963 Kennedy overhauled the whole FDA
program for approving medicines to be
marketed to the people and about 600 uh
patents okay where they were he
challenged them because he didn't think
that they a uh passed all the safety
tests and be the other test that he
wanted to use was efficacy you know does
this thing really work
Sean I believe Kennedy was a a radical
reformer in foreign policy and he was a
strong reformer in domestic policy all
right
and I and I'll just add and I I agree I
can't think of anyone
um any person or family that today uh in
the same
ranks and you know having that same the
only reason I make that comparison is
because you know they came they were
Outsiders that they came in they were
not and by the way this is not about
Republican Or democrats trumps are
Outsiders Kennedys were Outsiders right
they were not insiders right Johnson was
an Insider okay uh uh FDR is an Insider
you go to uh bush is an Insider you know
you're in the space that you're coming
in the only family you can compare to
only fam this is not about who's a
better president or not there's only one
family That Shook things up the way
Kennedy's did and that's the Trump
family so if you compare families to
families uh we haven't had a president
that people feared as much as they
feared Trump and Kennedy
the last time people feared a family as
much as they do hasn't happened for 59
years that's really interesting she
would bring that up about them being
Outsiders because what people forgot
about JFK
is that he was an Irish Catholic yeah
and he had a meeting it was impossible
for an Irish Catholic to become a
president
and he had a meeting with nehru the guy
from India yeah all right and nehru was
trying to lecture him on the evils of
colonialism of British colonialism and
Kennedy stopped him in mid-sentence he
put up his hand in front of him said
look
nobody has to tell me about the evils of
colonialism all right because my family
comes from a history of eight centuries
of being dominated by the British so I
don't have to listen to any lectures on
this topic you know and I that's when I
heard that story I thought that was such
an interesting perspective and I was
talking to Dick Gregory the late great
Dick Gregory one night and uh he said
that when he got back from Birmingham
the great you know tremendous uh race uh
riots there
Kennedy called him up
and he's and he's and and his wife when
he got in his wife said the president
called
and he goes really and he goes yeah he
says he wants you to call him back
and Dick Gregor goes well wait a minute
it's midnight
he said it didn't matter what time it
was and so he calls the white house at
midnight and Kennedy picked up the phone
and he goes dick I need to know
everything that's going on down there
please all right and so Gregory went on
for about 10 minutes
and he stopped and Kennedy said
I don't know if I can say this on the
air you can okay he said oh we've got
those bastards now all right and dicks
and Dick said and I started crying
because I didn't think any president
could ever say something like that and
he said it was he said after he thought
about it was because Kennedy was an
Irish Catholic he knew what it was like
to be discriminated against and that's
why he said that
so again going back to it to me
name your president in the last 80 years
that was part of the swamp and try to
drain the swamp and you know the people
that have the you know Country Club type
of people that have been in politics for
40 50 years who I mean let's face it our
president just turned 80 years old
our president just turned 80 years old
and he's been how long has he been in
politics
what is the 49 years I think the more we
have to celebrate the 80 years it's how
long he's been in politics there isn't
anybody that's been in the swamp more
than him if you were to look at the
swamp by the way this is both left and
right McConnell that that's a person
that's been in this game for how long
Pelosi worth a couple hundred million
dollars been into this business how long
McConnell's wife linked to China how
long this isn't a to me it's not about a
matter of uh uh a left or right or a
Democrat or Republican and now that this
is uncomfortable because I had Oliver
Stone here and I know politically we're
both of you lean and I understand that
part for me I haven't lived in Iran and
seeing what happens when people get into
politics and all of a sudden they take
control and use their powers to bully
people I can only think of two people
two families who had the audacity to
face him and one got assassinated and
the other one went through a different
kind of assassination as a character
assassination but it's a different form
of assassination because if you
assassinate to like I know what you guys
are doing with you know citizens
against political assassination
there are many different forms of
assassinating today you don't have to
kill today there's so many creative ways
of doing it both of these guys had the
brass
to go after the government I mean John F
Kennedy was an NRA member for God's
sakes can you imagine if today Joe Biden
was an NRA member what they would say
about Joe Biden you know that's supposed
to be a Democrat today John F Kennedy
would be a very different kind of a
prayer I think he he was the last
independent president that we had
that he understood things that was
needed on the left and he understood
things that was needed on the right but
the comparison of the two families I can
only find one other family Trump and
Kennedy and I I don't know if you guys
agree or not but those types of families
will typically be a big Target look at
families who are not a Target
why not look at families who are a
Target
Kennedy and Trump why
you're from you're from Iran from Iran
yes born and raised did you know did you
know that JFK commissioned a state
department study
on the cost and liabilities of bringing
back moshadec
did you know that okay yeah he did and
in fact it was him him and Bobby Kennedy
were so much against the shot okay that
they made it clear
that if you don't start reforming you
don't start opening up your Society you
know we we are going to think about
bringing back most of them and this
caused which I'm sure you're aware of
the so-called white Revolution which I
think is 62 and 63. all right all right
and so that's the very few people know
this which she ended up being wrong by
the way he ended up being what John F
Kennedy ended up being wrong to bank on
mosader because you know what that led
to uh well you're talking about the
return of the Muslim fundamentals sure
okay I you think Mozart there could have
gone against them you think he was
strong enough to fight against them
really I think monster dega Nasher could
have yeah I don't I think and Kennedy
favorite Nasser too so I think I think
it's um I think it's uh
you know as much as people want to sit
there and say you know what a great man
Jimmy Carter was
half the stuff that's happened in the
Middle East we can bring back to Jimmy
Carter half the stuff because Kissinger
could have helped him the shaw
Carter could have helped him they
promised they would
uh December 31st of 1977 Carter is in
Iran toast with the shot this is a very
important partnership to us they leave
we got your back
boom and then what happens today in Iran
the complete opposite is being happening
and women are being tortured women are
being killed
what's our government doing about it we
want to give money to Iran seven billion
dollars we want to give them 150 billion
dollars tell me how that makes any sense
so we can sit here and kind of go and
you know
um you're talking to a guy who watched
10 000 men flagellate their backs
walking on the streets of Tehran and I
lived there as a kid as an
eight-year-old watching outside my
window saying why is there a trail of
Blood on the on the ground
yeah I said this is a very different
type of a conversation to me the same
way why I love what you guys are doing
to push the envelope to get us to the
truth
we have to also realize man some of the
people that were behind this were dirty
people from the swamp
if you if you're saying what you're
saying who killed Kennedy the swamp
killed Kennedy no
well yeah okay so so then then there you
go that setup did it yeah so and he was
not part of the swamp right would you
say so would you say would you say Trump
is part of the swamp
no okay so they try to get him as well
tell me who's part of the swamp left and
right there's so many names tell me tell
me somebody today in politics that's not
part of the swamp let's see let's see
what name you're going to give us
give me a name that's not part of the
swamp that's a very powerful political
leader
I'd love to hear it I'm here well
go ahead people people in power for a
long time are get become part of the
game okay and there there isn't anybody
in power today either in the upper level
of the Senate upper level of the house
okay and Biden of course has been in
this I think the Senate since nineteen
1964 or something like that 72. you know
so you know they've all been there a
line they're very hard to dislodge I
don't have to tell you that okay they're
very difficult to defeat okay you know
because we have such a closed system so
I can't think of anybody right now in
the upper levels who is not part of the
game so the last so one thing we can all
agree on the three of us is
the last two presidents we had that were
anti-swamp were Trump and Kennedy
stuff that you have to agree to that
well
kind of uncomfortable I understand the
only reason I'm saying this is because
as much as
you have spent all these years
giving your case an argument which
millions of us agree with
who sit there and say damn
this is a pretty scary thought and I
agree with you a lot of this makes sense
who's the problem you guys the the my
challenge my biggest challenge when you
sit there and you're like hey you're
talking about all this stuff and you
make these arguments you have one more
step to go and you guys stay right here
you don't want to take that next step
you know what that next step is the
problem is the swamp
the problem is we the people forgot this
as their country
they're controlled by all these people
that play the same game it's the you
know hey uh guess what Sanders stepped
this one out Elizabeth Warren kick it
Pete Tuesday I want you to endorse Biden
uh Amy here's what I want you to do
we've chosen Biden's our guy hey I have
decided to stop my uh I appreciate all
the support but we've decided to stop
our election we're going to endorse
Biden and everybody in America is like
wait you were losing
and Kamala is going to be the VP what
he called you out in the election and
she is this a joke is this like are you
guys entertaining us like do you guys
think we're idiots
and then we have to sit there and take
it that's a little confusing as well and
the same thing on the other side now
here's what we're going to be doing and
by the way this isn't sitting here
saying
uh Trump's approach or how he is and you
know McDougall or is stormy and this is
not sitting there saying you know this
is just saying the swamp is so powerful
that the only two people who decided to
stand up to them one of them was killed
the other one's been character
assassinated for six straight years
since he chose to do it and and you have
to say there is some credibility in that
Patrick don't you think that the uh
what happened in Dealey Plaza sent the
signal to other people
that if you if you try and do something
about what's what we have arranged yeah
okay uh it can also happen to you
I believe this recruiter film is a clear
signal you know to anybody who wants to
really try and shake up the system but
but I but I think that like to to me uh
I think it also also it also should
inspire people to say I'm not backing
down
I'm not going to let you control my life
this thing as as important as I think I
am I'm going to be gone in no time life
goes on Mike has got to have an
opportunity like I do I'm not as
important as I think I am the country's
more important than me right I think
there are people like that in America as
well we're sitting there and say oh
you're going to do that to him and get
away with it
yeah I'm good man I'm I don't like that
let me go find 50 other people who feel
like me who are patriots let's go figure
you guys out and say you can't be doing
this but you know connecting that back
to the assassinations I mean I think you
you do have people like that you have
people you know when we've had these
previous investigative bodies that have
stepped up they've you know after the
the JFK movie came out a lot of people
are saying hey I'm getting older I I
want to I have records I have why is
this stuff still not released yet you
have people that have worked for these
groups you had the assassination
research community that are daring to
write these books and have these
conversations and these conferences you
know and and and challenge The Narrative
that's out there so I think we do have a
pretty good Cadre of folks that are
looking to Country first very important
you guys are playing a very important
role because it's it's it's patriotic
it's Brave it's not popular but you're
you're doing it and a lot of other
people who their job isn't to sit there
and investigate and research and pull up
articles and go back and read a how many
pages was the Warren report 488 yeah the
average person is not going to read a
reporter like going to be excited about
it you know the average person doesn't
want to read an 800 h a page uh romance
novel let alone a you know so can you
can you pull the percentages up of what
I just sent you put a little percentage
is up most people believe in the JFK
conspiracy theory this is five years ago
okay if you go up a little bit on the
percentage
yeah look at this you know where we're
at keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going right there so most
people leave JFK wasn't killed by Oswald
alone okay
61 percent
don't believe it and by the way it's no
difference between male or female 62 and
60. okay 56 of white believe others were
involved 72 percent of Hispanics 76 of
African Americans
College grads 52 percent no college
degree 65 percent so the age is 60 62
60. it doesn't matter Republicans
identical look at that 60 or 71
Independents think it's even more so
Independents are saying no I think it's
even more look at look at Clinton and
Trump Democrats a little bit less
that somebody else was involved Trump a
little bit more so this has got nothing
to do with politics people on both sides
are sitting there saying something
happened here why do we not know about
it now you
here's a uh here's a a question for you
behind closed doors the people that are
protecting this story okay that wanted
to stay the way it is which is a one
bullet you know the Magic Bullet that's
just it's what happens we gotta stick to
let's stop talking guys can you guys
stop doing these meetings and these
events like you're bothering us a little
too much your your pain
why do you think it's necessary for us
to know who did this and who was behind
this why is it necessary for us to know
why should we know why shouldn't we just
move on
well
I believe it you know it's important to
know from
the fact that
I don't think we've had an honest
democracy since
and what this is done as you can see
right there
yeah I don't know if you probably have a
another graph of this the
Public's belief in what the government
is saying when JFK took office was
something like 75 percent
all right
today it's in the 20s and if you look at
the graph
the single year biggest drop
was 1964 when the warn report was issued
so I I don't see how you can have a
functioning democracy if you have that
much cynicism and about and they've done
focus groups on this and an unbelievable
90 of the public believes that Kenny's
assassination caused a period of
depression and cynicism to take over the
country that had not really existed
before
I mean I'm sorry Jim I mean no go ahead
I mean I mean anecdotally that's exactly
what we heard when we were talking to
people
that very that exactly what he just said
we heard a lot of people use that the
phrasing is a little different depending
who you talk to but a lot of folks said
they grew up with a lot of people I
talked to who were Witnesses or Alive at
that time
um you know and they would say I grew up
you know thinking I need to I was
patriotic I care about my country you
know
um and they said that that whole period
shook their belief
in our country and for like I think a
lot of younger people
um you know I oh just a different graph
now but uh I know that when I talk to
younger people I talk to high school
students I talk to college students and
we use actually the assassinations as
educating education tools to think about
careers things like that you know like
nursing photography things like the film
and a lot of them just assume that I
talk to you say oh yeah conspiracy it's
not a dirty word to them you know and
they just believe that that's just the
way things are
and it's more often than not
and then the other part uh can can you
pull up the report he was talking about
from 77 zoom in a little bit to see when
it went up so 75 percent uh Eisenhower
60s Kenneth is public trust in the
government uh has gone from 75 to 77
under Johnson then all the way down to
it was down with Nixon down with four
down with Carter uh and then up with
Reagan downward Bush up with Clinton
downward Bush down with Obama a little
bit of up with Trump and then flat with
Biden the American people don't trust me
well I can't read it what is it that's
just a public trust in the government
what's the percentage today the
percentage today is less than 20 percent
20 it's even worse it's worse today than
it was it's ever been you know I mean go
under Obama Obama's was the lowest ever
where people trusted America it hit 19
under Obama heels fifteen percent under
Obama where people didn't trust the the
government uh and by the way I would be
curious to know what that event is that
caused it to drop to 19 that's a 17 15
or 17 15 so yeah people don't trust them
so you know again to me not trusting the
government what is the government I
think people don't trust the swamp is so
they don't trust the people within the
government they don't try us it's not
what it was before uh how do we how do
we get there how do you think we got
here to have this little of a trust in
the government well in in my opinion
when when you have a series of events
which um you know are I believe are kind
of like the equivalent of earthquakes in
the 1960s all right when you have you
know at four assassinations
all right that took place in a period of
five years under the most suspicious
circumstances and the and the government
and the Department of Justice don't do
anything
about them all right and this is what I
believe it eventually led to the
combination of the extension of the
Vietnam War
and to Watergate all right and in my
opinion since then it's it's essentially
been a kind of downward curve sense you
know
um the Watergate scandal took place over
two solid years all right and so you
know to restore the trust of the people
in the government
I really believe it's almost a lost
cause now I guess I like fighting for
lost causes okay please keep doing that
keep doing that you know what would be
an interesting thing for for you guys to
investigate next
uh I had a guy on uh General Spalding I
don't know if you're familiar with
General Spalding or not uh and
um uh General Spaulding says one day
he's given he's being asked he's working
for uh the U.S government he's being
asked he was a former general of the Air
Force lived in China for a long time he
was there to learn about the systems of
China comes over here
and he's telling her what China's vision
is long term
and on one side McConnell is sitting
down the other side Biden's sitting
there both of them were not happy about
his message about China because
McConnell's wife
there's lineage goes back to China and
the the power that his wife has and then
obviously Biden's link to China as well
neither one is happy and then he says
immediately I got fired right after they
hired me to teach them about China and
then all of a sudden I'm being fired I
think James if whatever you choose to
investigate next and study I would be
very curious if you would have any
interest in studying the swamp and
seeing what really goes on within the
political world you know how people say
they they they don't want this to be
released they don't want people to know
they well the title of the book should
be who is they okay let's go figure out
who this they Community is the they
party right because once we figure out
that they people who are protecting all
these things from people knowing about
it I think then then we can lead to
accountability but I think if you wrote
that book you would need 24 7 protection
to to make sure you're safe and I don't
know if you want to live that kind of a
life
probably not probably
not do we have our friends here from uh
Belarus we have one of them uh uh uh
okay so if we get one of them out
uh before we get these uh folks out here
to you obviously you've had to study Lee
Harvey Oswald who is he to you what kind
of a person was he you know we've we've
Read All About It we've seen his you
know inspiration his wife his you know
what he was linked to we heard what he
did to different folks who is Lee Harvey
Oswald to you well Lee Harvey Oswald I
believe is probably the most complex 24
year old yeah that probably anybody has
ever studied I mean I mean he he this is
a guy who's has so many facets to him so
many unusual moves to his life okay that
even though we only lived to 24 people
have written books about him all right
in my opinion I believe that Lee Harvey
Oswald uh was recruited into
intelligence work at a relatively young
age I mean how many marines
study the Russian language okay uh how
many how how many marines Dan get a
hardship discharge six months before
they're supposed to be regularly
discharged then go ahead and travel into
Europe and then the Soviet Union and try
to bargain with them about selling them
secrets to the YouTube plane and then
get shipped 400 miles out of Moscow to
mince because the KGB thinks he's just
fine all right then he comes back home
and now listen to this carefully
we're supposed to believe Oswald is a
Marxist right
who does he live with first the White
Russian Community who want to overthrow
Khrushchev and bring back the Tsar all
right and then where does he go next to
New Orleans
Cuban Exiles who want to overthrow
Castro and bring back Batista what what
kind of a communist does that kind of
stuff all right and then he goes back to
Dallas and he's so oh so lucky to get
this job at the Texas School Book
Depository which just happens to be the
building that the that the parade is
going to take a right turn in front of
so I I the secrets of Lee Harvey Oswald
are still coming out yeah all right
um do I have a couple minutes to explain
a very interesting thing
they Declassified the work of a woman
named Betsy Wolfe who worked for the
house select committee her job was to
study the CIA file on Oswald
she asked for every divisions Charter I
think there's nine in the CIA all right
she read over every Charter studied it
all right and then she did an imaginary
graph this is what Oswald's files should
have done at the CIA okay and then she
goes okay I'm ready for the file she
studies the file guess what Patrick it
didn't do that it didn't do anything
like that all right
his files should have gone to what we
call the SR division Soviet Russia
they didn't go there they went to some
place called the office of security
why is that significant the office of
security does not set up a 201 file all
right which that was the most common
file in the whole CIA all right and
everybody had access to it so she
started interviewing people
and she finally found a guy uh who was
running the Robert Gambino who was
running the office of security at that
time and this is what he said he said
look it doesn't matter how many
documents come in it doesn't matter how
they're pre-stamped
if the client goes to a place called the
office of mail Logistics
they will only send his files to that
department
what this means is that somebody was
rigging Oswald's file in the CIA in 1959
as he's going to the Soviet Union
why would you do that well it was so
unusual that those memos if you can
believe this those memos didn't get
printed in the hsca volumes all right
and in fact her work is all hand written
in other words it never got typed in the
memorandum form the only reason we know
about it is because the ARB put what
they called the delayed release number
on her memoranda what that means is
they've they figured that this can be
Declassified in say 2004 and this was
the classroom in 2005. that's how Secret
the life and career of Lee Harvey Oswald
is well let's learn about it we have two
folks here who actually spent time with
them uh uh gentlemen appreciate you for
uh being on here with us let me properly
introduce you we have Paul Gregory uh
who is uh uh yes who is a fellow uh
research fellow at Stanford University's
Hoover institution he's a pioneering the
study of Soviet and Russian economics he
holds a PhD in economics from Harvard
University he's the author and co-author
of 12 books and more than 100 articles
on economic history the Soviet economy
transition economics and comparative
economics and economic uh demography so
uh he wrote a book called The oswalts
and Untold account of Marina and Lee
Paul thank you for joining us uh oh and
uh being on the podcast and then we also
have Ernest uh Tito vets which I may be
butchering this last name forgive me if
I did but we have him here as well never
mind
he's in Belarus and uh he's also MD PhD
is a researcher author translator
interpreter he was a a member of the
Belarusian uh National sailing team he
has author or co-authored six research
books 14 14 patents and over 400
research papers and As an interpreter he
translated three books and uh wrote a
book called the real Oswald uh based on
his close friendship with the American
six decades ago had no reason whatsoever
either political or personal to murder
John F Kennedy gentlemen thanks for
being on
hello
hello Gary have you guys spoken to each
other before or no have you guys had any
kind of interaction
without a fixed change of uh email
oh so it's only through email you guys
have never done a zoom or spoken to each
other no no first time well we're glad
to make this introduction
oh fantastic fantastic awesome so if you
don't mind if if Ernest let's start off
with you if you don't mind taking a
minute and share with us your experience
uh with Lee Harvey Oswald so the
audience knows how the relationship what
started what year was it what he was
like give us a little bit of background
uh well let's
travel in time back to early 60s
in this country we were a rather
isolated Society
I was a fan of English I studied it very
hard and
well and I believe that's why I get in
touch to behind the audible
uh it was he came it was in 1960. and
that's the column meetings over
friendship was in that surrounding that
Soviet world at that time it was the
only Foreigner whom I could speak in
English too I mean a native linguistic
and also he was sort of
a window to the Western world not
materials politicize that was very
curious what people were there behind
the Iron Curtain
and our friendship
who was in at this nothing political
about that just two guys were the same
age
I met spoke the same language it was a
lot of guys around speak English
the English too and somehow we got
together it is often
that was it
while we just LED life of two young men
people who just
discuss things discuss politics discuss
music we were both found a music a music
classical music to go to Opera listen to
tape recordings
then just had a great time we say with
tape recorder when it started his
English
and there's a lot of fun
and so you know I can't go into detail
within the properties of other identity
time I just described all that in my
book also Russian episode
but what I want to say that I saw him as
a human being
there is no overlaid of those
[Music]
well what was after the assassination
okay so you when you when you hung out
with them you never saw him capable of
doing what he did like did he show hate
like you know how sometimes you're
hanging out with a friend like I have
friends in the Army we had a couple I
see at our level we have a several
friendly
mild person as I know him no aggression
at all and in my book I gave many
examples and
other people would have turned wild and
start fighting that was not all these
way got it and you know so my impression
of him was very mind
very a reasonable person it's very
important a rich person dedicated person
you know he studied Russian
before going to the Soviet Union and to
study Russian it's something it's a very
difficult language
and again interesting got it started the
system he came here to study this is
after the idea I will proving life for
poor and unpossessed in United States at
certain time the basically he he read
marks
in the teaching he found the book
somewhere in Dusty shells the library
and he was in a way it possessed with it
here he got the
drift of Mars General happiness and
everything got it let me go let me go to
uh Mr Gregory as well thank you for that
Paul how about yourself what was your
experience with him what was he like
uh I I think
Ernst new Lee uh during the best period
of his life he had friends uh he was
looked up to he was the only
uh American in uh Minsk uh so I
completely understand and accept ernst's
description of Lee in Minsk I met him
during another period which was after
his return
to to the United States into my hometown
of Fort Worth
where uh he and Marina
arrived Lee had expectations
of grandeur he was he was going to
publish his historic diary
he had written
um uh extensively on Marx angles
socialism capitalism and so forth so he
thought he would return to Texas as a
celebrity
um who could finally avoid a manual
labor labor uh job and I think he had
told Marina the same so
when I met him it was a period of
growing frustration
um there were no signs of of violence
other than the fact that
there was a lot of um of
abuse going on within that marriage it
was a guy's Eric in the back can we
increase the Audio I don't know why you
guys decrease it as much as you did I
can't hear for the last 10 seconds let's
increase by 10 points please continue
sir I couldn't hear you keep going yeah
let me try to that's much better that's
much it's not on you it's on our guys on
the back go for it oh okay I thought
you're talking to me no I was talking to
the guys on the map so so when I met
them
uh they were just
getting accustomed to life in in America
Lee understood that uh it was important
that Marina not know that they were
really starting out at the bottom of the
ladder Lee was making a dollar 25 cents
an hour uh he was telling Marina that he
was destined for for greatness
so um
and Lee and I would say something
interesting is the fact that it was
quite obvious that Lee did not want
Marina to understand American life
because if she understood American life
she would understand that they were
living really a life of poverty
so it was quite a concession when Lee
agreed that I would come to their house
regularly and speak Russian with with
Marina and with Lee by the way so
whenever we met we spoke entirely in
Russian so I would say
um I caught Lee at a point of of
increasing frustration
and uh uh so I would say that's that
that's the best I can do with describing
him well let me ask you this on one
thing I would say is although he was
working at manual labor he dressed well
he was uh very neat I think this was
also a characteristic of Lee and Minsk
got it so what would you say about
Marina what was Marina's personality
like was she uh uh was she also
ambitious and believing in his vision of
who he could One Day become was she Aid
saying oh my God Lee's a special man
he's one day going to be dot dot dot or
was she more like just a supportive
spouse
she was the opposite of a supportive
spouse because she recognized early on
that his Ambitions and dreams were
totally unrealistic got it so instead of
being a supportive
um wife with respect to his ideas which
he understood were unrealizable she
really
spoke with scorn about these uh wild
ideas
got it uh James what do you think in
hearing both of their takes with because
you've also studied him uh either what
questions do you have or what thoughts
do you have what they're saying I I've
met Ernst titovic okay he was in
Washington for a conference be a little
closer to the market he was I met Ernst
he was uh in Washington for a conference
I believe in 2014.
the first question I asked him
is when you first met Lee
did he speak good Russian and he said
yes he spoke very good Russian when I
first met him now
this goes back to the point I wanted to
make Oswald spoke good Russian when he
left the Marine Corps he went out with a
girl named Rosalind Quinn who was
learning Russian from berlitz to get a
job in the state department
she said Oswald spoke better Russian
than I did
and if you study this thing Russian is
one of the most difficult languages
there is to learn it's not like Spanish
or Italian one of those romance
languages it's a very difficult language
to learn but Oswald knew it good pretty
well when he left the Marines by the
time he met Ernst he was speaking pretty
much earnest would you say would you say
he was speaking fluent Russian when you
met him
oh well yes often considers with very
heavy American accent and I was under an
impression that whoever taught him in
English didn't pay my attention much
attention to Russian phonetics
otherwise he within he thinks domestic
household work
newspaper language he was quite
proficient and there was no problem
everybody around had no problem
to understand him
that's the way
and excuse me if I may if I may comment
on
Lee in the United States
just to continue what Gregory is said
you know Lee it was very determined and
I don't think he was frustrated in a way
as far as
what he wanted to accomplish was
concerned well in the first place he
delivered a brilliant lecture actually
Jesus desert college and professionals
that I believe he got University
education consumer proficient in Russian
affairs
and that was rewarding to his uh well as
a researcher again he uh delivered
rather participated in radio debates
exposing his views and he's there stood
against their experience anti-communists
and and take us through
[Music]
people and he went through with crying
flying colors
all that taken together means that he
the cosplay was satisfied he got
satisfaction the result of his uh well
political excuse me
some technical problem uh
medical activity again he organized this
fair play for Uber committee
I believe that was his idea starting his
own party
first as a fringe party and then to turn
it into a real party to put forward his
ideas and put in on practical run
so I think he was quite there was not
despondency in him at that time he
recently determinantly did what he
planned to do that's my vision of that
uh for Marina and Lee
Marina was rather practical woman
household things Earthly and he she
never interested in words in Oswald's
idea there was they were boring to him
she wouldn't listen to that
and as far as her ability to grasp
American Life why did she marry uh
Ernest if I may Earnest if I'm if I may
why why did she why did she marry him
either one of you guys Paul do you know
why she married him if if there is no
what what was the reasoning for the
marriage is it just uh
what was the motive was it to come out
here
ours could answer that better than I but
but the fact that he had an apartment
the fact that he was an exotic American
um
uh and the fact that she herself was
something of a of a Maverick so but
earned Ernst would have a much better
sense because I was not president that
time got it so Paul maybe let me ask you
a different question your friendship
with him or the relationship that you
guys had at the time and then when you
see the events that take place with
Oswald that did that um did you kind of
say you know I I because of my
involvement with a relationship I want
to know what really happened here as a
friend were you curious on the events
that took place with JFK assassination
where he said I want to know what really
happened to you you know what was the
motive why would they do something like
this and if yes what ideas do you have
with what happened with the
assassination
uh first let me let me speak to his uh
his Russian because uh he and I and
Marina spoke spoke Russian Lee uh lee
could express himself well in Russian
but his grammar was terrible uh and as
Ernst says Uh Russian is a very
difficult language
so if he were trained in some CIA camp
or some KGB Camp they probably would
have taught him better better grammar uh
with respect to my reaction to the
assassination
I was watching it on TV along with
everybody else I saw them bring us in a
suspect and immediately I saw it was Lee
and uh I would say within a few hours I
I more or less accepted the proposition
that he did it and he did it alone
so I've never really had a problem with
that
irrespective of the counter evidence
that I've seen
and he wrote that only those who really
uh well it's free
telling is what it said
support stories it include
support his theory so he didn't was uh
it wasn't after the best of the Earthly
life he was stoic and that was part of
his theory so he was ready to do with
all hardships no matter what to promote
his ideas
I would say the most important thing I
have to relate is is the fact
and Ernst may agree with this that we
have grossly underestimated Oswald he
was persistent he was a very smart guy
yeah he he had his goals which he would
pursue uh persistently
um
so uh and much of this is disguised by
the fact that I believe he was dyslexic
so if you look at his writing
uh in English and in Russian it's it's
pretty bad
so but I would emphasize the fact that
Oswald was not dumb he was a smart guy
had Street smarts he had as far as I
could see all the characteristics needed
for assassinating a a public figure and
we know from Marina's testimony and
other testimony that he barely missed
um assassinating General Walker in
Dallas which which which shows he has
the so-called soul of the Killer
uh may I have a word yet yeah let's
let's go final words here and then we'll
we'll uh you know well
I wouldn't I wouldn't say it was smart
or great smart with me who is quite open
and hit him a certain base in many ways
again I revert you I was so interested
to my book uh well
[Music]
violence wasn't in his character in the
first place and it was not in his
teaching he wrote it in black and white
that we are against violence uh he
believes that historic events after Marx
result in that the capitalism would be
next best political performation will be
socially he believes that those historic
courses will do without
what he wanted to achieve without him
residing and rising to violence and
again in literature there's controversy
about
and
attempt at
a general uh Wallace Walker Walker
Walker yeah and again
he had he committed this crime killing
president who undermine his teaching and
he that was where he would draw the line
no violence he were done he suffered a
lot to promote his teaching and to
results in committing this heinous cry
would be absolutely
well undermining his theory
then he would be alone
you know well nobody would believe him
anymore after this act so he was
absolutely against violence he was
absolutely against it so it's
interesting listening to both of you
guys because there is a different uh uh
feeling and view of him but gentlemen
appreciate you for making the time to
come out here uh Paul we're gonna put
your the link to your book below for
folks who wanted the Oswald's an Untold
account of Marina and Lee's and Ernest
once again Paul thank you for making the
time for joining us here on the podcast
appreciate you guys welcome thank you
it's our pleasure it's my pleasure take
care bye-bye so did you listen to this
either one of you did you hear anything
that's out of the ordinary they didn't
know
all right no I I've read on Earnest's
book I think at that time it was called
Oswald Russian episode and I met him
okay like I said in Washington
uh Gregory is essentially giving us the
one report version of of Oswald okay so
there's nothing you know that uh that I
haven't read about that can I make a
comment about the fair play for Cuba
committee all right they both commented
on Oswald in the fair play for Cuba
committee all right what neither one of
them said is some kind of important
information Oswald was the only member
of that committee in New Orleans all
right which is kind of strange they told
him the fpcc we wouldn't advise you to
do what you're doing in a Southern big
city like that all right he did anyway
all right and then the third thing is
a few of those flyers that also was
handing out
contain the address of 544 Camp Street
which I'm sure you're aware of you know
was the address of the office of a rabid
right winger who had ties to the FBI the
CIA and the American Nazi party a guy
who I'm sure you're aware is the name
guy banister so why would Oswald you
know be making these kinds of Flyers uh
based out of that particular building
all right and and these are paradoxes
that I believe that have to be explained
if you're really going to try and
understand who Lee Harvey Oswald was you
know and and I don't I I think today you
know
um there is essentially one solution to
this that that Oswald wasn't up what
they call anjan provocateur which means
he really wasn't uh doing what it
appeared to be doing that he was really
a kind of provocation agent okay in in
real life that's my idea and a lot of
other people who know the case somebody
just posted a Super Chat uh uh on onmar
Elma halawi Google order number 11110
JFK ordered since 1963 anyone that tries
to disrupt the current monetary system
gets killed the swamp exists because the
FED a private entity is in charge of the
money supply you hear the story with the
FED what uh what have you found with
what John F Kennedy wanted to do with
the feds some say he wanted to end it
you know some were not happy about it
what do you know about that do you want
to take that one I I don't know that's
that is that's not true okay that thing
about the FED order all right it's not
true the way some people spin it uh it
was really a technical kind of uh change
that Kennedy was making all right uh it
was not but Kennedy did have a dispute
with the Federal Reserve and this is why
he hired a guy named James Saxon to be
the Comptroller of the currency Kennedy
did not think that the Fed was making it
easy enough to borrow money okay and so
Saxon became his agent in that he wanted
to sanction more lending for small
farmers for small businesses he even
said you know I don't like the Federal
Reserves uh uh their description for
qualifying for loans and he then tried
to encourage the opening up of more
State Banks that would have
more lenient uh lending requirements all
right and so in that sense in that sense
yes Kennedy was trying to oppose and I'm
sure you're aware that the Federal
Reserve is essentially represents you
know Wall Street in New York you know
the Rockefeller Empire the Morgan Empire
in fact I think they're signed on to the
actual constitution of the Federal
Reserve the warburgs and people like
that we're a part of of the Federal
Reserve and like you said Kennedy was
not from that particular branch of the
power elite
yeah I held a meeting in the room at
Jekyll Island where you know the the
whole meeting took place and I don't
know if you've been there or not it's a
very interesting place uh where you know
you've actually been to Jekyll Island
I've been at Jekyll Island I flew our
guys in
um chartered a plane flew him in took
them there show them through all the
homes all the vacation homes how they
lived in this community and what it was
like and you know some guys stayed in
some of the properties it was a very
interesting experience see uh what
Jekyll Island is but it's actually I
don't even know why they went there it's
not like the nicest place if you go to
it it's not somewhere where you say oh
my gosh what a beautiful place for all
these billionaires to have a place to
live it wasn't that fancy I understand
some people's Fascinations with it but I
wasn't enamored by it it wasn't nothing
that I was underwhelmed more than
anything else when I left I I think you
should Jekyll Island was the place where
these very powerful and rich people went
to formulate the idea
of a Federal Reserve Bank okay so that's
that's why it's important in history
yeah yeah the the have you ever read the
book The Creatures of a Jekyll Island
what'd you think about that yeah it's a
very interesting book a lot of
interesting information in that which I
didn't pick up anywhere else you know
yeah and and again another conspiracy
there's no way these guys have that much
power what they do they don't that's
another one that goes back and forth so
do you think we'll eventually get to a
time well when you and I are alive where
we're gonna know what happened or no
uh you you mean with specifically John F
Kennedy yeah assassination do I think
well no I as far as the actual specifics
of what really happened I think it's too
much of a Cold Case okay uh I think we
can
I think intelligent people who know the
material can make a very kind of what we
call informed speculation of what really
happened I think that's becoming more
with the work that the ARB did
especially and which I mentioned before
about these documents on Vietnam and we
didn't get to talk about one of the most
Sensational discoveries these guys made
which was and I'm sure you're aware of
it operation Northwoods okay you want me
to explain that yeah okay operation
Northwoods was a wild scheme that was
dreamed up by The Joint Chiefs of Staff
in which they would create what they
call a causes belly a great event that
would provoke an invasion of Cuba some
of these were having uh you know uh
Cubans uh Cuban refugees go on a killing
spree in Miami all right uh another one
of them uh was to the most bizarre one
was to fly a drone
over Cuba
have a tape playing we're being under
attack and blow up the plane okay and
that would be the excuse to go in and
invade Cuba and Kennedy took a look at
these uh and he says uh no I I I don't
want to do anything like this all right
and this was brought to him by Edward
Lansdale and our Lyman lemnitzer okay
and then Leominster said well let's go
ahead and invade anyway
so and so Kennedy fired him all right
and unfortunately uh by hooker by crook
he ended up going to Europe and being
part of the whole NATO agreement anyway
so these are some of the things I
believe are very important in trying to
put together some kind of feasible
scenario Northwoods is really kind of a
scary kind of because if you want to
talk about false flag I mean it doesn't
get any more bigger than that of our
false flag
let me let me uh let me ask this
question from you when when say that
John F Kennedy Declassified documents
all of them are out and we have them are
we going to see anything is that going
to be like oh my gosh you know how come
you kept this from us from so many years
is there going to be anything
revolutionary and then the the second
part of the question would be the
following
how do we know they're going to release
everything anyways you know how are we
going to know that some of this stuff's
not going to be kept that never made it
out to us so two questions one will it
be that revolutionary too can they hold
back some documents that they don't want
us to see well I'm in agreement with uh
James here that I don't think that we're
really going to ever get a full clear
picture I mean we all want that I mean I
was a reasonable a lot we've been doing
the work we've been doing over the years
and pushing for release of Records
um I think it also uh ties to the fact
that you know when we started our work
we knew of a lot of CIA and FBI records
but what we didn't realize was all the
other types of records that were out
there that people brought to us or we
were able to to look and discover
um did I answer the second part okay all
right so so I don't think that I'm we're
really going to see I think we need to
keep pushing though we really need to
keep pushing do you think we're going to
see anything
uh I I really can't answer that question
with any kind of authority I think there
might be a couple of interesting nuggets
but if you ask me Patrick
with what they already did
what that was a big a huge what they
call a Quantum Leap already it's just
that except for people like you and you
know and there aren't that many of you
you know the MSM just doesn't want to
acknowledge a lot of this stuff and I
believe it's because of uh number one
they missed a boat on the assassination
on what really happened and number two
they completely missed a boat on the
cause and effect between what happened
to Kennedy and then what happened later
like for example the the whole Vietnam
War debacle you know so they just don't
want to deal with this kind of thing and
I and by the way
I believe that the MSM has gotten so bad
that kind of opened a door for people
like you okay because people want to
hear you know contrary to what they say
they want to hear this kind of stuff
it's so funny that you're we're showing
the the the numbers of the trust the
American people have in the US
government you know how much of that
matches the trust people have in the
mainstream media you're exactly right
the main the the lack of trust in the
government of mainstream media matches
so what does that say about the two
maybe they're on the same team yeah so
that's another part of the swamp this is
why we need people like Kennedy's we
need people like Reagan we need people
like Trump we need people who are
willing to push the envelope on both
sides of the aisle boy that that is a
really shocking yes wow
yeah
you're right you're right it's what is
it 21 do me a favor match it with the US
government match it with what you were
shown with the US government so if you
can put those two look at that that
right there the the lack of trust in the
Public's lack of trust in the US
government
matches its historic lows right now it
matches Publix lack of trust go to the
media in a media so the media equals the
government so maybe they're just a uh uh
a spokesperson on behalf of the
government here you guys I want you to
say this to the people and they go and
tell us no wonder people don't trust the
media and the government today yes so it
it helps uh uh when guys in the media
that are not in the podcast side there's
a lot of them right now that are pushing
the envelope who are very interested in
this
um
Rogan's done a fantastic job
interviewing a bunch of a JFK
assassination he's done a phenomenal job
at it a few of us have put some time
into it as well but it's great on what
happens when you try to control the
people people eventually find a creative
way to get the message out to others and
then people say wow I'm starting to not
believe what you have to say I think you
guys are both full of [ __ ] mainstream
media and the government and I think
that's a good thing and that's why the
whole purpose of us having everybody on
the podcast here today just so you know
I don't know if you know this or not
we're coming to the last minute here was
to challenge you to write a book on the
swamp I think it's the next chapter of
your life for you to take the next cover
couple years have some courage you're a
great author you write stuff that makes
readers look into stuff so if you say
JFK Revisited Through the Looking Glass
okay where this should say
the swamp Okay Looking Through the Glass
House that they live in right and we all
pick it up and you're not afraid of
going after people on both sides uh I
think that'll get a lot of people
interested especially nowadays anyways
uh any final thoughts before we wrap up
we'll go with you and then James you'll
take us home well we just saw each other
in Dallas the other day and you know the
question came you know there have been
so few people that have been connected
with the investigative bodies that have
written a book about it and I've been
trying to get my book out for a long
time I even did a sabbatical we call an
off-campus Duty assignment you know to
do research and life changes have
written in other books since then
um but that's that's actually my next
step is to really you know uh be able to
finally get my book out especially the
par part though is my record group is
released now I always have to be careful
because of my connection with the review
board that I can only talk about the
things that I can talk about you know
which is a real thing you know but uh
but that is my next step it's and I
think that's yeah awesome looking
forward to it James well I I'd like to
thank you for for the appearance uh and
I think it's uh I I like you said
earlier even if it's a lost cause this
deserves to be talked about okay because
I think the the the mass of the massive
American people contrary to what the MSM
says really wants to know what happened
and they deserve to try and know you
know what really happened because as we
both agree the assassination of
President Kennedy was an earthquake
moment you know in increasing when
people become presidents do you think
when people become presidents and they
go to Area 51 or whatever it is because
you know the the there's only been 46 of
these guys one day become president you
think they fully know what happened or
they still keep it away from them as
well no I I I I believe well let me tell
a story
after Barack Obama was uh re-elected
into his fifth year one of the guys who
was working for him
asked him what you know what happened to
all the hope and change
and Obama said uh you saw what happened
to JFK didn't you
so I think that's kind of what happens
you know
I don't know if the fear of death should
be that that uh
um
man I don't know I don't know if you
have to choose between the truth and
death I'm not convinced that people are
willing to live a quiet lives of
desperation and hiding if they know the
truth just to live a life that you're
gonna disappear in a few decades man
you're not as important as you think you
are no matter how rich how famous how
powerful you are your life is going to
be gone and people gonna move on with or
without you you know and I think I think
maybe that mindset
of getting to the bottom of it scares a
crap of some people but I do believe
there's going to be some True Believers
that are going to rise up and say yeah I
need to know exactly what's going on we
need more people like that we need more
True Believers anyways appreciate you
guys for coming out thank you for your
great work that you've done uh thank you
also for last minute we call you to fly
out and get on a flight here with us and
uh come to Florida gang tomorrow
I'm doing a podcast that I've been
looking forward to doing for a while I
am very very curious about what's going
on with Brazil tomorrow I'm having two
folks that are going to be on the
podcast one is Rodrigo Constantine and
the other one is uh Paolo figuerdio
who's the son of the former president of
Brazil that'll be on the podcast here
and we're going to be talking about
what's going on in Brazil it's a mess uh
I can't wait for that podcast tomorrow
for those of you guys that are
interested in the prison topic we will
address that tomorrow take care
everybody bye-bye bye-bye thanks